maintenant un autre sujet mais qui
concerne toujours la batellerie puisque
à auxerre mais son déclin à auxerre il
n'est pas récent il date on nous a dit
de la disparition des vignobles le port
sur l'yonne était donc jusqu alors
suffisant mais jusqu au développement du
tourisme fluvial et pour y faire face
auxerre a décidé de bien séparer les
deux activités
chacun chez soi en ce temps là les
péages n'avait pas encore remplacé les
écluses au pied de la cathédrale les
péniches venait chercher le vin
d'auxerre pour priver alors pour
l'emmener vers paris aujourd'hui les
péniches sont beaucoup moins nombreuses
et elles se partagent des lieux avec de
nouveaux venus
les touristes quant au port il n'est
plus adapté aux besoins des navires de
commerce
la municipalité a donc décidé de créer
une nouvelle zone portuaire
nous sommes ici sur le site dont des
pieds draps et des clairions qui se
trouve à côté là et nous souhaitons
aménager donc un port de commerce à cet
endroit à bon port de commerce qui
pourra être évolutif et après aller
aussi de l'autre côté puisque nous
sommes dans une zone d'activités
importantes zones d'activités avec les
zones industrielles sur la rive droite
de l'yonne avec une zone d'activités
tertiaires une zone artisanale sur la
rive gauche donc ici une fois la
batellerie dans ses meubles le port
traditionnel subira lui aussi une cure
de jouvence
le tourisme fluvial est en pleine
expansion mais les infrastructures ne
sont pas toujours adaptés à l'heure
actuelle avec 40 bateaux le port est
plein l'opération ne consistera pas à
l'agrandir mais à aménager les abords et
les différentes zones pour tous les
usagers il faut que tout le monde
cohabite il faut que les plaisanciers
puissent y venir et avoir un certain
nombre de services à côté des bateaux il
faut aussi faire cohabiter les
promeneurs il faut faire cohabiter les
joueurs de boules il faut faire
cohabiter les pêcheurs il faut faire
cohabiter les grands bateaux et les
petits bateaux et c'est tout cet
ensemble donc qui est en réflexion à
l'heure actuelle qui ne pourra se faire
que par tranches parce que c'est un très
gros projet à l'échelle d'une ville
comme auxerre si on veut faire des
choses très soignée ça coûte cher mais
on n'a pas du tout le droit de massacrer
ce site une date pour le port de
commerce et le déménagement des péniches
1989 le coup quatre cent mille francs
le port de plaisance évoluera à plus
lentement parallèlement à la
restauration du centre ville les
déviations routières sont presque
terminés on va pouvoir s'attaquer aux
aménagements des quais les voitures
juste retour des choses et seront alors
la place aux bateaux